ein hubschrauber ein
aufgefahren
wer sich zum feuer
ich bin zugs kann man dann beim 35 mm
flieger abwehr zu und seit 1996 in
sandwich stationiert
[Musik]
wir haben die aufgabe den luftraum zu
sichern und dem wir mit dem radargerät
ziele erfassen und mit unseren
fliegerabwehrkanonen bekämpfen
[Musik]
hier wie es die papageien stellung
bezieht
ende die mister ist eine lenkwaffe mit
kurzer reichweite
ich habe ich mich entschlossen dabei zu
bleiben weil mich das waffensystem
extrem interessiert haben aber ist er
wirklich ein tolles gefühl wenn man
fühlt sich richtig gut sagte mann die
waffe abgefeuert
hier ist die parteien stellung beziehen
ende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der flugbetrieb über war dass sich die
räume und ist verantwortlich für die
rechtzeitige alarmierung der eigenen
kräfte also in der natur draußen zu sein
ist aber so scheint für mich ist mein
traumjob
[Musik]
wir haben eine beobachtungsstelle bis
rund um die uhr besetzt fünf tage zehn
tage wir versorgen und somit anders über
kurven rasen schlafend rasen richter fr
6 viktor brothers sechs ein hubschrauber
feind erster zug in rahden steuerung
abwehrbereit
werden sich zum nächsten
abgefahren apfel feuer
[Musik]
[Applaus]